straight up
freestyling night straight up
freestyling night playing these random
songs off the YouTube music
library yeah no cost no copyright
infringment sight yeah I can just
freestyle unleash this appetite and
share these jams these freestyles yeah
all day and all night this family is lit
tight yeah yeah that
simulation yeah that's the
down basic needs basic
[Music]
needs number one focus is
the basically Prosperity now simple as F
there is only the whole [__] may
as well dedicate our life to the basic
needs sa the tight those Food Forest in
the water wells yeah nextg energy the
housing in
commun yeah where are we going to go
this freestyle is going to flow all over
the place maybe some
nity maybe some D maybe some random
nonsense yeah you
know
and we got another angle over there yeah
you can check me out there huh you're
just checking yourself out everything is
that same nothing this freedom freedom
[__] everything everywhere at
once no separation or entities no
location hope everything is coming
through great hope you can hear the
musical play yeah hope you can hear this
mic this Wireless one so that I can move
around so that I can move around like
this like
[Music]
this I don't know these songs at all
this is a complete freestyle of the
unknown so let's go take a look at
what's next I don't even know I'll
sample the track see if it's even good
and then the float and we'll see what
unfolds
[Music]
y' all right that one was
dope what is this
[Music]
one okay yeah we can do this one let's
see where this
goes uh yeah okay
okay okay where is this one going to
flow we don't know it's a freestyle yo
freedom freedom [__] it's all
over the place already no destination
this is the [__] destination every
single move is check mate everything is
already [__] Freedom everything
is already Freedom there is already no
entity there is already only the
nameless flow Oceanic love and freedom
unconditional love and freedom appearing
as everything in sight not only the
stream but even miss Souls flying
through the air and bombing innocent
people that's still unconditional
freedom and love that's still the
universe of love that's still it
everything is it these words are it this
food is it this water is it everything
is it everything is it every everything
is it every everything is it without any
lack zero lack [__] 0 0 Zer lack
z0
lack There's No Lack there's no entity
to lack no entity means no [__] lack
that's right [__] simple as that
uh so simple and true so simple and true
uh no reason to
fret no reason to
fret everything is perfect flow best
thing you can
do is do nothing because there's no you
it's just all happing UN
autonomously in the flow yeah
no doership and no control the freedom
of that is so a blow to the sense of
me all right what's this
one okay well let's play Let's
Play okay hard that one that was
good not feeling that one so much
[Music]
what's going on up
here let's try this little
one okay let's go a little
slower okay a little bit slow let's see
what
flows let's see what
flows okay let's see what
flows simple Maybe a bit out of
control let's see what looks maybe a bit
out of
[Music]
control
okay yeah [__] so simple [__] so simple
there's no one here it's that [__]
simple no one there and no one here this
is nothing is talking to itself it's
everywhere it's a simple [__]
it's too simple [__] is like the
sky or the wind just blowing on through
yeah try to over complicate things no
such thing as over complicating this
it's too easy too simple to understand
nobody can grab it box understand
yeah
okay let's see where this goes with the
know simple simple simple yo all this
[__] [__] on the internet all
this
[__] war and violence war and violence
break that [__] PW of the fool
ha separation porn got you gra it
grabbing grab it for more separation
porn got you grabing grabing grabing
grabing for more box box box box box box
box separate people separate Nations
separate ideology separate religions
these are not my people so they don't
deserve resources they don't deserve the
basic
needs dumb ideologies of Separation
which are Perfection are keeping this
place feeling like it's not Paradise
even though it's obviously Paradise
obviously
Paradise after this paradise feeling
some Deja right now I feel like I've got
a clue no entity inside the nothingness
thatwe at
once no one to grab no one to box just
the simple flow of this wind so simple
just a simple flow of the Wind
[Music]
simple flow of the wind simple simple
simple simple flow of the wind simple
simple simple flow of the
[Music]
wind next
track
[Music]
let's see this
one so live
chat
[Music]
up okay we can play around with this one
see where it
goes yeah okay where does this one go
who knows do a little zoomy on the base
see where the pace takes it the tree
like the
Bumblebees no separation is the key to
Creation all you got to see is through
the elusive Nation yeah that's a
[__] joke all the da there only
one thing happening here and it's
nothing being every [__] thing
it is way too simple for the sense of me
that contract feeling in the body is a
joke that feeling of lack is a joke
because it's literally the entire
universe contracted into a center point
ha that's [__]
hilarious you all know that [__] is so
ignorant but it's Perfection AR Rising
ass ignorance isn't that [__] a cosmic
joke
yeah that [__] is so funny man it's so
funny and it's also the very thing
that's creating all the goddamn War all
the feeling of a Center Point H this
[__] is really good actually this slower
beat is what we need
family this was probably one of the best
freestyle
yet good to
know all right that was good man I like
that one let's check this one
out
[Music]
see
okay you want the
Empire but the the Empire is made of
it's a s that is a [__] s that sense
of
Separation bried because there is
already none of it yeah there's already
[Music]
separ
yeah
soing yeah
okay we just got an update that the beat
is way louder let's see if I can bring
the beat down just a little
bit okay maybe that will
help that should be better that should
be a lot better
okay all right let me know how that
sounds now
fam okay so we bring the beat down a bit
makes it easier to cure the free
freestyle voice of the artist yeah
okay okay okay Bringing Down the voice a
little bit of the music so you can hear
the rapping thank you for the update
that it sounds better appreciate the
adjustment yeah okay okay okay okay yeah
[Music]
okay
you know [__] it's way too
simple everything is one thing there are
no separate organisms everything is one
whole it is so simple and way too
[__] simple you can say it a
thousandfold a million times it will
never change it's the same rhyme it's
the same pointing said a thousand
different ways a million different ways
it's all pointing to the thing between
your ears is nothingness it's
everythingness it's so simple it's
everything at once the whole universe is
you it's so simple you fool nowhere to
go no separation to bridge everything's
already one
organism yeah it's that
simple no more added Concepts no more
added understanding just Dow simply just
Dow when the body's empty it Dows it
fills basic needs for the thousands for
the Millions for the billions the whole
planet want organism basic needs for
children and adults letting everyone
play and be abundant hey that was
fun
um but I'm not going to give that one a
heart though I mean it might be good
to um we do Len that one but it might be
good to know that I did it
though
um I guess I can go based on the
pages yeah that's what I'll do I'll go
based on the pages because this is page
one of
many
yeah in the categories of hip hop and
pop
on the Creator
music and it's great because all of
these uh the views the usage details are
you can use it and monetize when there's
no attribution required which is
great and just YouTube will probably
credit
them let's go to the top we got up
here this is so
silly okay okay let's see what happen
music like it's a commercial yeah yeah
it's a commercial for Freedom commercial
for the freedom that's
already Freedom
commercial I don't think I can do
that can't do that one
either do we just do this
[Music]
one
yeah I think we did this
[Music]
one what's
this oh yeah I think I remember this
song from something I
[Music]
added okay okay yeah yeah I remember
this from actually the Epstein
documentary I use this in that
documentary okay yeah that's what the
sense of me
does sense of separation is all about
itself it just wants more for itself it
will take anything possible in sight
objectify it to try to fill the void
inside which is impossible to fill
it can just be it it's that simple just
be
it hey you want to be a rap superstar in
the comments it just is [__] it
just is [__] it's just flow and
freestyle yo it doesn't even matter
though nothing matters though it's that
simple energy nothing matters yo
everything is one energy it's obvious
for no separation in sight
[Music]
no it is a bunch of random [__] it is it
is it is a bunch of random [__] like an
R generator yo like a generator yo just
a creativity generator
[Music]
yo
too many
possibilities in
sight love
[Music]
it okay maybe we finish this one up and
the next one we will stand up because
it's cool to play between those two
cameras in my right am I am my right
this one I can stand up is prettying
cool and on this one I'm sitting down
and I'm not a tool maybe I'm a th that
is right I might be a fool come in
sight probably goon is the best way to
describe
it cuz there was that coming B being a a
rap Superstar or an interviewer or a
YouTuber or a dow homie and a
homesteader and a new energy Creator but
probably just
goon is the description that we're
looking for okay let's heart that
one what we'll do is we'll stand up on
the next one did we check this
[Music]
one probably pass
ass okay okay let me play with this
[Music]
one where's this going nobody knows
pretty [__] simple nobody between
those ears nobody anywhere pretty clear
pretty simple just like the dog like the
cat like the baby no name no
name pretty
simple it's not even an entity between
the just simple flow just like the wind
brushing through the leaves of the trees
rubbing through the grass grass wavering
like that that's all all all of this is
some random energy
creativity just it's already it's
already it's already only the whole
there's only the
whole basic needs is all that is
simple everything is one connected web
of the same energy simple has that may
as well just serve that what else is
there to do nothing nothing there is no
worth in trying to get for yourself that
insatiable appetite will never lead
anywhere it will always feel empty
unfulfilled unfulfilled I'm constantly
unfulfilled I can never get satisfied
because I keep objectifying everything
in sight wake up wake up there is no
[__] subject there is no [__]
subject and nothing can be objectified
everything is already F fil everything
is already in ho it's so simple just
bounce up and down maybe get a little
bit titties and bit sound uh uh
uh uh uh uh uh maybe a little Freedom
with the nip freedom of rubbing the
[Music]
[Applause]
nip
that was a pretty fun
one do some chinups perhaps here in a
moment we
will let's
see all right next
page so this little this little icon
means it's an instrumental which is
also
nice let's see what's this one
[Music]
okay okay
okay
okay I do
[Music]
it
okay
[Music]
okay okay we wanted to get a chin up huh
CH okay okay got three got three pretty
[Music]
be yeah
you know how it is when we are
whole when we are
whole everything so simple easy flow
when we a whole when we a whole it's
simple easy flow but when there's that
feeling of I am separate and I lack and
I need therefore all I do is try to get
try to get for myself because I lack for
myself anything I can get for myself can
I keep getting more and more things
maybe more and more things will make me
feel whole maybe they'll make me feel
fulfilled more and more more and more
more and more more I am a special unique
person with the journe in my life
[Music]
story your empty space I love you but
you are nothing it's too easy because
you're
everything you're all local you're local
everywhere at once you're the whole
universe it's so
simple okay let's see what's next what's
[Music]
next
m
[Music]
okay really grateful for all the
fam the live
chat Community the bonds these unspoken
beautiful
Unity together we in harmony so simple
so
simple obviously nothing matters more
than basic needs new
communities new Energy new
infrastructure modern
housing for free everyone deserves to
live for free live for free basic needs
met wake up every day and all you do is
play all you do is contribute creatively
that's what we're meant to do that's
what a baby is destined to do that's
what the dog cat have inside innocence
and Purity and sight and then it's
corrupted by all those narcissistic
ideas of me me me me me me more me me me
me me me more I lack and therefore I
need I need everything to feel
whole what a
contraction losing the Purity and
innocence is not worth it don't focus on
me the center point which is an illusion
so simple as that all there is is the
hole so serve that easy peasy squeezy
lemon easy is that
easy and we'll do a little stretch
perhaps
like this little bit of this side little
bit to that little bit this way a little
bit of
that uhuh that feels great
okay
[Music]
cuz I don't give a [__] what you say
yeah I'mma do [__] my way so you can go
kick roack bricks up what
[Music]
I all right let's
play okay we'll kick back on this
one kick back kick back easy as that
simple as
that it's just putting up your nose a
little bit losing the mind is a
compliment no ideas no Concepts no
knowing of anything at
all I know nothing that's good knowing
nothing is emptiness simple simple no
nothing innocent Purity innocent andity
inocent andity inocent andity inocent
andity was all there always there always
there never left never left never left
it all never L it
[Music]
all okay okay okay okay okay
okay nothing to say because everything's
already free everywhere I wants what is
there to even say nothing everything is
nothing everything everything is nothing
happening very simple and easy nothing
to say just un know everything
everything un know it all oh there's no
entities anywhere there's just that one
hole everywhere pretty [__]
simple [__] it's so easy it's so
simple it's no other equal it's all
equal it's all simple all equal so
simple that decentralized autonomous
organism yeah and
organization solar Punk future
everywhere yeah basic needs met for
everyone every single body functionality
is to play is to have a great day is to
be abundant so easy
[Music]
[__] all these Matrix protocols [__] all
those handcuffs all those [__]
old jobs [__] all that slavery and
[__] [__] all those Fiat currencies
all that [__] labor all that [__] is
[__] nonsense nobody wants to
work at any of these industrial
complexes no thank you no thank you
everyone deserves to be free every
single body deserves to be free do
whatever the [__] it wants without
having to wake up and go to a shitty job
yeah [__] that [__] that [__] that
[__] [__] that [__] that
[__]
[Music]
[__] that was a fun
one yeah
what is
[Music]
this
okay where this going to
[Music]
go what a hilarious
game that this all
is already no separation anywhere yet
the illusion of separation is everywhere
yeah Warfare is a product of that yeah
missiles are a product of that rap and
pillage is a product of that illusion or
separation saturating Every Nation all
of creation because it is the way that
this creation place in
it's it's a beautiful
[Music]
creat yeah that's how it plays that's
how it plays that's how it plays what a
beautiful
day
yeah all there is is universal love not
individual love there is no
individual there's only the
universal that's all there is that's you
all of the fa all of it is you all of it
is you fool all of it is you all of it
is you to all of it is you your
[__] to all of it is you all of
it is you best thing to do is serve all
of that you fool stop trying to suck for
yourself that will lead you to
just un
fness repeating same pattern over and
over again trying to get it from clout
from object from substances from
relationships from experiences from
anything other than your [__]
self which is be Freedom big self it's
already here there is no path directly
to the sitting in that [__]
chair already what's listening to these
words what's watching the video
stream there's no path to that it's
already simple as that no [__]
path to what is already that everywhere
at
once in that body in all bodies there is
no path to what is already even the
illusion of separation it already
everything is it everything is done cing
Freedom everywhere at once everywhere at
once everywhere at once all at once
that's you everywhere at
once so
simple
okay that was
[Music]
fun okay this will be
fun let's stand up for this
[Music]
one do
do everything at once everything at once
everything at once everything at once
yeah Universal Universal Universal all
there is even that contracted experience
of being an individual is it everything
is it everything is free everything is
free everything is free everything's
already free energy everything's already
free energy everything's already
[__] m everything is that
everything is that every single word
every single word that's heard
everything everything is it everything
is it every single move is it every
single viewing is it every single word
is it everything is it every single
movement is it everything is it every
single thing is it the phone or computer
that you're watching this on is it this
camera that I'm talking to is it
everything is it everything is it no
separation
at all it's one ocean of love everything
is one ocean of freedom and love it's
all perfect everything that's appearing
is perfect even war and greed jealousy
Envy materialism everything's it
everything is love Perfection and
freedom everything is
it everything is
it everything is it everything
everything everything is it everything
everything is it
all right let's see this next one that
was a fun
[Music]
one where you going to take me where you
going to take me where you going to take
me with the jams with the jams peach jam
blackberry jam strawberry jam yeah I
love love all flavors of jam I love all
flavors of jam yeah I do I like it with
peanut butter peanut or almond butter is
very good too yeah I love my p&j I love
my p& J Peanut Butter and Jelly Time
Peanut Butter and Jelly Time Peanut
Butter and Jelly Time Jelly Time PB and
J BB and J PB and
J maybe chop up some bananas throw it in
there too maybe some mixed
berries maybe maybe some
granola yeah that is so yummy and tasty
yummy and
[Music]
tasty and then we maybe do a little
booty shake booty shake boot booty
shake booty shake booty
shake booty booty shake booty shake
booty shake maybe we even drop it low
booty
shake booty booty shake uh uh booty
[Music]
shake freedom freedom free style freedom
freedom freestyle everything is possible
no contracted boxes yo it is that simple
everything is free and possible
everything's already that free and
possible no contracted boxes no
contracted bounds no contracted boxes or
bounds nothing can hold this together no
structure no idea no concept possible to
hold it all because it's absolutely
[__] free already all the time
forever and always empty and whole and
free simple Perfection everywhere
ordinary simple
Perfection simple freedom and love
everywhere all the time no single
Bounder box nothing can hold it together
because it's big banged and free every
we all the time at once no separation no
distance no time no space everything
together at once pretty simple
[__] pretty simple and ordinary
[__] shake that ass a bit more
shake that ass a bit more shake it shake
it shake it yeah shake it shake it
huh Shake It Be Free be free shake that
ass shake that ass then you flash the
camera with those
nips that was a fun
[Music]
one maybe a couple more and then we'll
wrap
okay let's see where this
[Music]
goes let's see where this goes let's see
where this goes let's see how this flows
let's see where it goes where is it
going to go where is it going to go it's
simple and
extraordinary
flow every
everything everything all right a couple
more
[Music]
Pull-Ups
d
free free free free free
free
yeah free yes it's
all nothing can attain the freedom it
already
is is it's just thinking about itself
and the freedom that it already is
that's all that's happening in the
Stream freedom is talking about itself
yeah every single word is freedom
talking to
itself in this case is talking about
itself how free it
is how free it
[Music]
is
what's this
[Music]
one okay let's check this guy
out okay probably wrap with this
[Music]
one okay so this was our first freestyle
we took it everywhere everywhere
everything is already free
and there's only basic needs it's pretty
[__] simple [__] there's
nowhere to go upon this realization yo
and it's not even a realization because
it's what already is there is no entity
inside there's only the Hess everywhere
I once everywhere I once everywhere I
once so basic needs freedom is where we
go and build have fre things the future
it's really simple it's really
simple water wells Food Forest NextGen
energy housing and communities Joy
Wellness Prosperity abundance waking up
every day to play It's that simple
[__] yo look at the solar Punk
future yo really [__] simple one
harmony with
nature
regenerative sustainable future abund
and prosperity for all it's way too
simple yo it's way too simple yo there
is no [__] entity yo there is no
goddamn location inside there's only
Everything at Once nonlocal ONN local
flow there is only all the universal
flow every single word is [__]
Freedom every single listening is
[__] Freedom every single
object like the phone and computer is
freedom everything is [__]
Freedom everything's freedom of
appearing as no matter what everything
is freedom appearing as no matter what
everything is freedom appearing as no
matter what everything is freedom
appearing as no matter what everything
is freedom appearing everything is
freedom
appearing everything is freedom
appearing it's already free and whole
love Perfection and freedom Perfection
and freedom Perfection and freedom
you've ever left impossible to leave
impossible to leave nobody can leave the
Perfection of being everywhere at once
I'm local [__] I'm local
[__] everywhere at once so basic
needs infrastructures are the obvious
solution to abundance for all pretty
[__] simple [__] it's so
simple it's way too godamn [__]
simple there's nowhere to go after this
there's nobody to choose or do anything
because it's already
[Music]
done
all
right
[Music]
cool all right let's look at that one Al
like we just listen
to and we'll go ahead and we'll fade
this one
[Music]
out all right let's Zoom this guy out
make it easier to see okay all right
well uh thanks for everyone tuning into
to the first live stream all you [__]
no buies out there
um five bro yeah let's go fam let's go
much love much love in the live chat
yeah really simple stuff man um yeah
nobody is here um it's everywhere at
once and it's already free and perfect
and so we'll have more fun uh free fre
style streams like this where we're just
[__] going wild and free and um
rapping about decentralizing basic needs
and the freedom that everything already
is and just [__] checking out these
jams and these artists um it's been
really fun man it's been a fun first
freestyle
stream um got me to do some pull-ups
which is great I love
that and um yeah man just the [__]
Goonies out here you know just the
[__] Goonies that in s and um and
that that the
um the uncorruptible
childlike innocence of play and freedom
that already is
so um bless bless truly
bless basic needs abundance for
all no here
[Music]
anywhere already
free okay
[Music]
bye
yeah